je pense que quand on a vécu c'est un
peu facile à dire de comment il faut
vivre surtout quand aujourd'hui on a le
confort d'un bon salaire le confort
d'une vie aujourd'hui qui n'est plus à
construire durant cette année j'ai
validé ma licence mais ce qui n'est pas
peu dire j'ai commencé un certificat
d'études d'études politiques
et puis j'ai essayé d'avoir des quelques
moments de liberté avec avec des amis
dans les interstices que le gouvernement
nous donne est tout simplement je crains
vraiment qu'avec cette pandémie on se
dirige vers une sorte d'habitude des
restrictions de la liberté sur sur
plusieurs pans on a vu que la santé est
en train de devenir quasi obsessionnelle
on a oublié que normalement ce qui se
passe après la vie c'est mourir donc on
est en train d'essayer de prolonger les
jours de vie mais est ce que dans ces
jours on a un peu de vie c'est à dire ce
qu'on a des moments on peut partager des
monts peut profiter je ne suis pas sûr
on a vu quand même de fâcheuses
tendances et des mauvaise pente à l'état
d'aller grignoter des petits pan de
liberté qui normalement de aurait dû
rester et aurait dû appartenir un cercle
très privé
donc est-ce qu'on va s'habituer ce qu'on
va réussir à se sortir des griffes
liberticide de l'état je n'en suis pas
certain
notamment des soixante huitards avant il
prenait des slogans qui était très
intéressant et pour la liberté prenez la
réflexion il prenait même la nuance à
une époque c'est pour vous dire comme
les temps ont changé et maintenant
malheureusement on les voit très vite se
valider les décisions du gouvernement
sans réflexion faire des plateaux ils
sont tous d'accord entre enfiler les
chaussons du conformisme comme comme je
dis dans le livre
ça c'est la première chose après il ya
les médecins et les médecins qui parle
de confinement comme c'était la solution
miracle et même s'ils recommandent le
confinement on oublie les dégâts du
confinement c'est à dire que on oublie
les étudiants qui vit dans l'ain 9 m²
tout le monde n'a pas la chance de
travailler pouvoir sortir et rentrer
comme le font tous les médecins et puis
il ya au quotidien toute une époque
en quelque sorte une partie de l'époque
qui fracasse la jeunesse sur des idées
qui ne s'intéressent pas skelly qui ne
s'intéressent pas à ce qu'elle pense
qu'ils ne s'inquiètent pas parce qu'elle
regarde ma tout ça je pense que c'est
préoccupant et ça fait de nous une
génération fracassé il fracasse on ne
sait pas pourquoi peut-être parce qu'ils
ont vécu des bonnes années ils ont vécu
les trente glorieuses ont vécu des
révolutions culturelles des révolutions
de moeurs et c'est très bien pour eux
ils en ont profiter maintenant je pense
que quand on a vécu c'est un peu facile
à dire de comment il faut vivre surtout
quand aujourd'hui on a le fort d'un bon
salaire le confort d'une vie aujourd'hui
qui n'est plus à construire
aujourd'hui tout ça ils oublient et
c'est dommage parce que je sûr qu'il ya
plein de jeunes qui aimeraient qu'on les
entende
je reproche à ma génération un certain
nombre de choses je reproche des très
beaux combats
je trouve ça merveilleux qui se
manifeste pour la libération de la
parole de la femme comme on dit
maintenant pour le conte pour le climat
je trouve ça merveilleux les combats
qu'elle mène un peu partout maintenant
je trouve qu'au sein de ces combats
qu'il ya des excès je trouve que
lorsqu'on parle d'une cause j'ai
l'impression qu'on passe parfois
totalement à côté j'ai l'impression
qu'on quand on se bat pour le féminisme
et qu'on interdit à des gens qui n'ont
rien à voir avec ces causes las de voir
un film par exemple celui de polanski
pour panneaux mais je trouve que c'est
contreproductif canton quand on met des
slogans des affiches pour abattre le
patriarcat ça arrive et ça ne va pas
résoudre certains problèmes et n'empêche
certains policiers ne prennent toujours
pas les plaintes pour viol donc ça c'est
des vrais débats et j'ai l'impression
qu'ils y sont totalement occulté par ces
espèces de slogans et cette radicalité
qui est mine de rien de plus en plus
omniprésente je dis que c'est une
génération sans charme parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui des petites
futilités paraissent tout de suite très
grave est de plus en plus on ne cherche
pas à voir et je parle au sein de toutes
les discussions on ne cherche pas à
comprendre les faits on cherche à savoir
comment la personne n'a vécu et le vécu
malheureusement n'est pas une opinion
le véhicule n'étaient pas des faits
c'est un ressenti et si on commence à
prendre le ressenti de chacun comme la
norme alors on va avoir beaucoup de
choses à changer dans ce pays